it's tacky broken soggy fix yourself
you're a mod you should be able to fix
yourself in some way what to play I
haven't had a Stafford gambit accepted
yet mmm thanks for that double the pawns
I wonder who has the most interesting
name backwards
let's play Bishop is it before and this
and then tinks yeah you can call me sire
let's take here if I take here Queenie
too is an interesting mode waiting for
us if I remember after this game I I
have a story with Queenie too so I
wonder if my funk played this because I
I what's a college epatha them jebaited
so Queenie - is a blunder because of
King d7 it's incredible
I had this once years ago and and over
the board puts game as just winning a
piece why I can't recapture because this
is a threat a pawn masoor in the chat
says how dare you yeah you shouldn't
always trust me it's such a funny like
you know black wins the material by
developing the king now queen g4 is is
also interesting green g4 will try and
target the king but then King CSIS the
Queen's attacked by the bishop and the
Kings so safe here and yeah white a
white should now be regretful not taking
the bishop when when they had the chance
it's very rare that you can win material
by developing your king I'm pretty sure
I showed this in some some st. Louis
chess club lecture I showed this
position it turns out the whites King is
actually less safe than blacks King
he'll I have this threat and this threat
this is just fretting a Queen trade this
is running to attack the rook and then
Queen c3 ideas there's some funny line
g3 Queen digs B to Brooks he won Queen
c3 came here and then Bishop g4 with a
pin but that
after takes there's a fork so it's
called it's called the pork held
straight Queens
so I'm Alba case I have an active King
not bad to have an active King as we
transition into the some kind of middle
game and game this Bishop is gonna try
and do damage so he felt like king b6
these Kings just chillin don't forget to
leave a like oh yeah for the youtube
people click the like the like button
especially if you like this King I have
to show your wanted to say show your
love I'll show your like let's play c6
the kingdom might continue to get some
exercise visualg for it's time to
develop more things do like this and
this
just put the rooks in and then
eventually Nate c4 oh I blended but
opponent missed it
I allowed each three and the bishops
just trapped h3 Bishop had to move here
and then this oh but then I had this so
it was probably okay
[Music]
e to is a nice almost kind of delicate
square if night moves away I'll have
rookie too if H three all have either
position you 6.95 hey another sub has
boots what does that mean does that just
mean you have boots hey listen the
counter-attack yeah when you're being
attacked you can you can defend or you
can counter-attack the Suites two trades
this pawn is no weak I'll have some more
pile up what does this move it's kind of
shocking
let's take so many options let's take a
pawn
yeah so many pawns falling Yasser would
be so proud Oh where's my mates oh yeah
I want to meet with like the both rooks
in the night probably to do that
it was rookie to Knight takes e5 King a3
rook a for meat or maybe white will flag
check a tough game I'm sorry I may be
deceived you
I said Queen e2 is a tricky move yeah
but this is this a nice way to make
youtube content is to trick my opponents
into entering some beautiful trap so
yeah people watching in the future on
YouTube and people watching on twitch
hope you enjoyed that beware like don't
you should not usually develop your king
but in these weird cases sometimes it
wins material